Muller's testimony was such a massive  disaster that even the most hardened  liberal resistance members couldn't help  but tweet their heartbreak and just like  Hollywood and the Democrats did their  dramatic readings of the mullah report  remember that we're gonna do the same  with their sad sad sad tweets disgraced  anti-trump Harvard Law Professor Larry  tribe writing far from breathing life  into his damning report the tired Robert  Muller sucked the life out of it  former obama chief strategist David  Axelrod adding this is very very painful  former CBS anchor Dan Rather tweeting to  think that Robert Muller should be the  main actor in the drama was always  misplaced casting thanks Dan and finally  filmmaker Michael Moore a frail old man  unable to remember things stumbling  refusing to answer basic questions